-We're about to play a gam
of charades.
Gal and I are a time, but Tari
is going to need partner,
and I think we found a good one.
She's been hanging out
with us all week.
Her new album "Younger Now
is available now.
Please welcome Miley Cyrus
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Nice to meet you.
-You, too.
-Hi, buddy. Hi, pal.
Alright, now listen.
Yeah, I know.
-We've been friends all week
-But not now.
-Here we go now.
-Putting time on the friendship.
-You all know how
to play charades.
Each player gets a turn
giving silent clues
to their teammate. 30 second
on the clock per turn.
We'll do four rounds,
then the fifth round
is a charades showdown.
-Ow, ow!
-We got this.
-Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
Gal, why don't you
start us off tonight
since you're our guest.
-You got it. Okay. Phew!
Just so you know, I've never -
I never played this before
Now I do it? I start?
Okay.
-Yes. okay, yeah.
I don't know how
to answer that.
Now I do it, but yeah.
-How do you do a song?
How do you film? TV?
-Film, TV. Yeah.
-Songs? Songs.
-Yeah, but that's
not the hard part.
That's not the hard part.
-Okay.
-You'll have to have me guess...
-Okay, okay.
-Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no.
-No, no, no, no, no, no.
-Listen, it's going to be okay
We're going to do great.
-Oh my God. I hate losing.
-Have faith in me right now.
-I hate losing.
-We got you guys.
Alright. Go, go, go, go, go.
Pick a number. Pick a number
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-We can do this.
Come on, buddy.
-Okay, now I just start?
-Well, you do one.
You can't talk.
-Shh! Okay.
-Don't tell me to shush.
I'm the one guessing.
I have to talk.
-Ready?
-Yes. Sorry, yes.
-Hmm.
-Song.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah, cool.
three words.
-Yeah.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Uh...
-Jimmy
"Birth of a Nation?"
[ Laughter ]
"Baby Got Back?"
Push? "Push It!"
Yes, second word.
Two. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Three words.
Third word, running?
Birth, okay, run.
-Ahh! It was that bad?
I thought...
-No, no, no, no.
What was it. I got it.
-"Born To Run."
-Oh, "Born To Run" of course
-The song.
I'm so mad.
That was fantastic.
That was my fault.
-[ Laughs ]
-No, that was fantastic.
-That was really good.
-That was fantastic.
Miley, it's your turn.
Oh, I'm so upset.
-All right, here we go.
-I almost want to be
with their team now,
but I'll be with you.
-My turn?
-You're talking out loud
right now. Yes.
[ Crowd shouting numbers ]
-I'm going with my lucky number.
-Your lucky number is three?
-That's three.
-[ Gasps ] Yes! Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Song.
-Mm-hmm.
-Circles?
Round?
-Not middle finger.
-The second word.
-Oh, "Wrapped around my finger?"
Oh, ring.
"Ring Around The Rosy?"
Ring around --
Oh, "Ring Of Fire."
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-No one celebrates
like that, by the way.
What number is it? Eight.
Someone's like, "eleventy!
Are you kidding me?
[ Laughter ]
-What is it?
What?!
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
You ready?
-Yeah.
Film. One word.
Short.
"It."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-What?! Yes!
-Okay, that was psychic.
-Are you kidding me?!
Yo!
-That was psychic.
-That was the best thing
that's ever happened
to me. I mean, come on.
That was the best.
-I think it's because
Jimmy's a clown.
-Oh, yeah right,
a scary clown.
-What do we have?
Okay.
-Are you that cool?
You're that cool, no reaction?
Look. He's holding the camera.
He's about to wind it up.
There you go.
-Okay.
Movie. A movie.
-Alright.
-Two words.
[ Laughter ]
-"Jurassic Park?"
Yay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Jurassic park."
-You don't want none.
-"Jurassic park"
"Jurassic park?"
I mean, give me a break.
Alright, now, this one,
Miley, me and you.
-What?-
Me and you go together
at the same time, and we giv
our teammates clues.
-Okay, all right.
-Whoever gets it first
wins 10,000 points,
and bragging rights.
-And money, dollars.
And really, no dollars.
Yeah, right.
-Jimmy's paying out of pocke
just cause he loves this game.
-I guess we're choosing
number 7.
You didn't want
to ask your buddy?
-I felt good about this on
from the beginning.
-But, then I want somethin
else, but you did lucky 7.
-I just, I like the number
-Let's do it, alright?
Me, too. ready?
-[ Gasps ] Okay.
-Okay.
-We have to act it out
together.
-I know. Yeah, hold on.
All right, ready?
You can do this.
-Okay. I got it. All right
-Alright, ready?
-Yeah.
Song.
-Song.
-One, two, three, four, five
six, seven, eight
"Supercalifragilistic
expialidocious."
Disco. "Disco Night."
Ahh...
-Push?
-Twisted sister.
-The moon, stars.
-Stars, the moon.
-Don't look at her!
Look at me!
[ Laughter ]
-"Push."
"Raise the roof."
-Dance, dance.
"Dancing With The Stars."
-No.
-"Dancing In The Moonlight."
-Dancing in the sky.
-Dancing under the stars.
[ Buzzer ]
Oh!
-Do we tell them?
-"Dancing On The Ceiling!"
-You were so close.
-How did we tie?
we tied!
-We tied.
-We're all winners. Come on!
Come on!
Our thanks to Gal Gadot,
and Miley Cyrus.
-That was great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-[ Laughs ] Very funny.
Thank you very much.
Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
I'm Steve Higgins.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And to my right is author an
multiple Academy Award winner,
the lovely, fantastical
Emma Thompson.
-That's what I'm talking about
[ Cheers and applause ]
To my left is the host of NBC'
"Tonight Show
and Saugerties sweetheart
Jimmy Fallon.
-Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Emma.
-Yes.
-Whom are you playing
with tonight?
-Tonight I am playing...
Well, he's currently starring on
Broadway at the Court Theate
in "This Is Our Youth,
It's Michael Cera.
-Michael Cera!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jiminy Christmas!
-Michael Cera.
-Hello.
Hello.
-You're going down, buddy.
-I'm feeling good, man.
We're feeling good, man.
-I'm feeling really good.
-Jimmy.
-He's feeling really good.
-I had a lot
of carrots back there.
-I have one question for you
-Yeah.
-Who's your partner?
My partner is the four-tim
Emmy winning star
of the hit CBS show
"The Big Bang Theory,"
Jim Parsons!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
-Oh, my God!
-So excited!
-I'm so excited.
-Wow!
-Yes!
-We are ready!
-Let's play some Password!
-Very good, here we good.
-Oh, my God.
Shut the front door.
The rules of the game
are very simple.
-What are they?
-I will give each of you
a password.
Then each of you
are to give a one word clue,
one word only to your partne
to guess the password.
If a clue is determined
legally by our judges,
you will hear this...
[ Buzzer ]
and you will forfeit your turn
-Calm down, man.
-I was getting angry.
I get angry when people
don't follow the rules.
-Alright.
-The team with the most points
after six words wins.
Any questions?
-No.
-I was just --
-First clue goes
to Emma and Jim.
-Okay, here we go now.
-Oh, yeah.
-What?
-The password is cruise.
-Emma, why don't you
start us off.
-What?
-You start us off.
-I'm starting, okay.
-Yeah.
Um...
Okay. Oh no, I don't think
that's quite fair.
Pleasure.
-[ Blows ]
[ Laughter ]
-Sensation?
-Hmm, no.
Leisure.
-Took a conservative guess
-What?
Say it.
What is it?
What?
[ Laughter ]
-Tom...
-What?
-That's what I was gonna do.
[ Laughter ]
-Tom...
-Hanks
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
-Almost.
Down to four points.
-I was gonna to do that.
-You gotta go.
You might win this.
-Was it Hanks?
No, it was. Hanks
was not the correct answer
-Tom. Tom.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not Hanks.
-You can say it again.
You can try it.
-Tom.
-There's pleasure and...
Is it obvious?
-It's obvious
if you know it, I guess.
Um, cat?
-Oh, tom cat.
No, no, no.
Down to three points,
three points.
Jimmy Fallon, three points
-Do I look like an idiot.
-Focus!
-I have.
-Ready?
-Yes.
-Suri.
-Oh.
-What did you say?
[ Laughter ]
Like the voice on the phone,
Siri?
-No, I did not say that.
-No?
Like Sori?
-Suri.
-Like Tom...
-You better get it, Jim.
-Suri, pleasure.
-No.
-Not pleasure.
-No. Just...
Suri.
[ Laughter ]
-Tom...Jones.
-Jim!
-Emma.
Your turn, two points,
for two points.
-That is ridiculous.
-I really hope I know it.
-I think you know this one
-I think I got it, yeah.
-He's got it. He's got it.
Just say anything.
-Tom
-.Cruise.
-Thank you.
[ Dinging ]
-Two points.
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I confused you.
I'm sorry.
-Okay.
Gosh, sorry.
-The password is nerd.
-I start?
-Michael, you go first.
-Michael's turn.
Michael's gonna go first.
-Geek.
-Computer.
-Oh, so close.
-You're gonna get this.
[ Laughter ]
-You have say something.
One word.
[ Laughter ]
-Sheldon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Nerd.
-Yeah.
[ Dinging ]
-Wow!
-Oh, my God, the score.
This is a barn burner,
barn burner.
Third word.
-Third word, here we go.
-Third word.
-The password is sausage.
-I got first?
-You go first.
-Oh, that's fitting.
[ Laughter ]
That's not fair.
-Ohm we're first.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Bratwurst.
-Sausage.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-We're having a sausage part
over here.
-Alright now. Michael and Jim.
-The password is sweater.
-Jim, you're going begin.
This one is worth five points.
-They've got 11.
-Okay.
-How do we have 11 points?
-Do they start?
-Points go down.
Somebody explained it
to me backstage.
-It's 36-1.
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Something happened.
-Should you go first?
-Definitely.
-Yeah. I think so, yeah.
-Oh, wait.
-No, go ahead.
Go ahead.
-What?
-You go first.
-I don't want to break
the game or anything.
-I don't know the rules
that well.
-Yeah, we're just making u
as we go.
-Bratwurst, everyone
would have said sausage.
-It was a good one, right?
-You got the point
because you went first.
-Wow. Fine.
-I'm just saying.
I'm just saying.
-Oh, snap.
Hey, alright, alright.
Back to the game.
-A lot of timing in this game.
That's all I'm saying.
-Michael, please.
Back to the game.
Let's see if you can make
the magic happen.
-Keep your people in line,
Thompson.
I'm just saying.
Go on, go on.
-Back off, back off.
-Alright, alright.
-I'm sorry for what I said
-No, I'm sorry, too.
[ Laughter ]
Just move on there.
Here we go.
One word only.
One word.
-Here we go.
-Angora.
-Oh, well.
Sweater.
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's serious
when he goes first.
-Angora.
Alright, here we go.
It's 11-8.
-The password is thong.
-Oh, my gosh.
-No, it's yours.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-I hate that word, so I'm no
going to say that word.
-Okay.
-Undies.
[ Laughter ]
-Panties?
-No.
-That's the word I don't like.
You can't say that word.
It's a gross word.
People don't like
to say that word.
-What word?
-They don't say what he said
-Panties.
-No, stop saying that.
-I'm going to say it again
Panties.
No stop saying it.
Undies.
-Undies.
-Bloomers.
-Undies, panties, alright.
-Well, you're giving him
clues now.
-I am. I am.
Just hold that thought.
-Hold that thought.
Hold that thought she said
That's not cheating, right
-Okay.
You're holding the thought
-I got it.
-Painful.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-She's acting.
She's acting.
-Hey, hey, hey.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
It's not charades.
-How do you know she was actin
and not just making
an adjustment?
-That's true.
-Painful.
-Thong.
[ Dinging]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is it.
This determines the game.
-I think when they change th
rules, they determined the game.
That's fine, you know?
Whatever.
-The password is pot.
-I just did this.
-Alright, whatever.
Mike can do it.
This has gone to hell
in a hand basket.
-What's your other hand doing?
[ Laughter ]
Alright, here we go.
Now.
Now, Mike, are you
going to start.
-Oh, man. Where do I go
with this.
Oh. Oh, man.
Oh, I'm cracking.
-No, it's good.
It's more than one word though
-Marijuana.
-Hmm.
-Nice.
-Oh, was that your go?
-Oh, sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-That doesn't count.
Judges.
Judges, that doesn't count
You can do it again.
-We have to cut that.
-Yeah, yeah.
Okay, wait. Weed
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on!
Bring it home!
-Ganja.
-Wait.
-What?
-You didn't -- You thought -
-That confused him.
-How did that make it worse?
-What. What was the first one?
-We had a drum roll
for [bleep]sake.
-Weed.
-Ganja.
Pot.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Our winners!
-Oh, it's been
such a pleasure,
such a pleasure.
-Oh, thanks.
-Everybody wins!
-Thank you so much.
Take care, buddy.
-Our thanks to Emma Thompson
Jim Parsons, Michael Cera.